8h50 centre bourg de saint claude de
diray heures de concert pour la
trentaine d'élèves de l'école primaire
de ce village de 1800 habitants pas
besoin de se déplacer pour ces jeunes
scolaires c'est le spectacle qui vient
directement à eux et en bus aménagé
c'est une opportunité pour nous puisque
même si nous ne sommes pas très loin de
blois eh bien nous sommes un petit peu
éloigné des des centres culturels
d'aider des lieux de culture et quand
nous devons proposer ses activités à nos
élèves ce qui est un grand plaisir pour
nous de partager ça avec les élèves
eh bien nous devons toujours nous
déplacer et cela à un coût très
important pour pour l'école et pour les
parents qui sont sollicités évidemment
par notre intermédiaire
pour programme concerts découvertes
autour de la musique de la renaissance
la spécialité de florence bolton et de
benjamin perrot ces deux musiciens de
renom sont les initiateurs de cette
itinérance musicale de quatre semaines
un peu partout en région centre val de
loire
l'idée en fait de cette tournée c'est de
toucher un peu tous les publics et en
priorité les publics qui ne viennent
jamais au concert qui ne connaissent pas
la musique ancienne et en milieu rural y
en a quand même pas mal
et l'idée c'est de comme ce bus est un
endroit dans lequel on a envie de
rentrer voilà ça permet aussi de faire
venir du monde qui n'est pas familier
finalement des concerts de place de
village en quartiers urbains d'écoles
élémentaires en établissement pour
personnes âgées
l'opéra bus va ainsi donner 60
représentations en quatre semaines dans
25 communes de la région
[Applaudissements]